you've been paying attention over the
last 48 hours you've seen the mainstream
go fringe and it's dangerous material
they can't always handle it 11 online
and the latest is this conspiracy that
Melania Trump actually uses a body
double so it all appears to have started
with this tweet that says this is not
Melania - think they would go this far
and try and make us think it's her on TV
is mind blowing yeah
mind blowing CNN covered this the
Washington Post covered this the view
covered this look at this picture
compared to this other picture of
Melania Trump this had everyone asking
the same thing does Melania Trump have a
body double any idea out dumb that
sounds of course Melania has a body
double
we freethinkers have known that for
years our minds are open but the
establishment is just now asking the
questions that we already answered way
before we even knew what the questions
were body doubles are everywhere always
happen body doubles were invented in
Europe by the first Queen Elizabeth so
she could sneak off on weekend to
perform with her improv troupe yes
they did the Herald's naturally the
troops the troops name give a dog a
throne which of course eventually split
off into two groups
half of them formed whose line of
succession is it anyway and the other
half were beheaded body troubles have
been used ever since to provide cover
for powerful people to maximize
efficiency and attempt to exert
dominance for example leftist Hollywood
star Amy Adams gets exhausted making so
many movies so isla Fisher steps in
Sebastian Gorka doesn't have enough time
to dispense all that wisdom so
occasionally he passes this podium to
this big turnip and even I Jordan
Klepper have been suspected of using a
body double
they say my body double is the detective
from Iron Giant or Beeker from the
Muppets but that's ridiculous
of course of course I'm powerful enough
to need a body double but trust me when
I use mine you'll never know
make no mistake body doubles are
everywhere in politics it's a well known
strategy we all know Hillary Clinton had
a body double on the campaign trail
she's admitted it we have it on video
it's incredibly damning right here she
was asked if she uses a body double just
skip to her answer it is absolutely true
dad art not one but two Hillary's were
running for president and somehow
neither of them could figure out how to
get to Wisconsin but this is just
distraction don't pay attention to this
this Melania body double thing is trying
to throw you off the scent like a
perfume that tells lies the big story
the double that's happening in health
care take a look at this the success or
failure of a bipartisan fix for
Obamacare insurance markets could hinge
on the White House the president seemed
to endorse that temporary plan but he
appeared to turn away from the deal just
hours later right there right there
right there you seeing the flip-flopping
the different opinions just hours apart
I know you're thinking Trump's body
double went off-book shut up that's
absurd Trump doesn't have a body double
they're not ready yet
they've been only growing beneath the
Arizona desert for nine months give it
time no Trump is using an even more
advanced technique the opinion double on
Tuesday President Trump proudly stood up
against Obamacare then he supported
measures to save it and by sundown he
proudly stood against it once more
you see opinion doubles let Trump occupy
multiple stances on health care at the
same time they allow you to play to
whichever room you happen to be in if
you have every opinion you are
guaranteed to be right it's brilliant
why I bet on every horse but look body
doubles our real opinion doubles are
real mixed doubles are real fun to be a
part of if you've got good DS but what
is it real is by partisanship it's an
evil conspiracy that reared it's unreal
head this very week look who's behind
this so-called bipartisan deal to save
Obamacare the Republican chair of the
Senate Health Committee and his
Democratic counterpart announced that
their plan would reduce premiums on the
individual market and prevent millions
from losing coverage this-this-this
right here
Republican and a Democrat rising out of
the swamp to find common ground I don't
buy it
you think politicians are going to work
with their enemies just to help
Americans what's the catch we need to
look closer let's look at these two
people patty Murray and Lamar Alexander
these masterminds are conspiring to undo
democracy notice anything similar look
at the angle of their head now look at
the glasses look at the digital boxes
their heads are in virtually identical
the answer is right in front of us patty
Murray and Lamar Alexander aren't two
different opponents heroically putting
politics aside to help America they're
one person fiendishly trying to create
middle ground not a body double but a
double body probably called Patty Lamar
or Murray Alexander or pal examinee
murmur from the proud state of Tennessee
Shawshank Tim one disgusting independent
politician appearing as two human beings
which is way more believable than
bipartisanship in Washington DC they
thought we'd never catch on
[Music]